Lauren's right. Now, we're going to move on and talk about the Central Nervous
System Depressants or CNS Depressants. These include the Barbiturates, the
Benzodiazepines, and alcohol. The CNS Depressants slow activity in the Central
Nervous System, and the Benzodiazepines and Barbiturates are used medically to
treat anxiety, as well as insomnia. In general, the benzodiazepines and
barbituates produces effects that are similar to alcohol. In fact, these three
drug types are behavioral, motor, and cognitive inhibitors. A person may
respond to a low dose with feelings of relaxation or decreased anxiety.
However, in some people that same dose can produce aggressive and even violent
behavior. In general, the CNS to presence can cause motor impairment, cognitive
impairment, slurred speech, disorientation, mental confusion and even amnesia.
We're going to send it back to Lauren to talk about these three drug types.